now they will face zach wheeler wheeler
his fourth game one and two with an era
of three
they have the first pitch of the day
that one's head out toward left center
field moniak ventures back he didn't get
a great jump but he finishes beautifully
a diving grab
as he robs tommy lestella of an extra
base hit to kick off the game
wow talk about being ready
[Applause]
i mean
first pitch of the ball game probably
not what moniak's thinking but boy he
had some great closing speed like we saw
last night
this ball was cooked
slicing away from moniak and he just
runs it down he flat out outran the ball
tom
ground ball to shortstop natan's got it
flips the second for one over to first
in time a 6-4-3 double play
his double play percentage coming in was
third best in major league baseball 22
percent of the time he's able to roll a
double play when needed
the phillies are coming up to face logan
webb
there goes segura and the ball is lined
up to center field to base it segura
will keep on rolling and he'll head to
third it'll be first and third with one
man down
harper did that a couple times last
night yeah and he's staying through it
and it's just not trying to do a whole
lot with it it's a tough pitch runners
lead off first and third at the 3-1
pitch
breaking ball and that's fall four just
below the zone that was really close
and that'll load it up
[Applause]
for brad miller just gonna have to throw
and trust
the power sinker
he does
la stella
crawford belt got him
what a terrific turn by the giants as it
goes 4-6-3
and webb gets out of the mess in the
first inning
[Music]
one ball and one strike
and nikki moniak shoots it the other way
for a base hit his first hit of the year
and that's got to feel good
and here's nick maton who had his first
major league hit last night
one for
four and he lights one to right field
that one toward the corner that's in for
a base hit it hits the wall in one hot
money can run he's around third being
wave told by gary jones the throw to the
plate he is safe
maton slides into third the phillies
take a one-nothing lead here in the
bottom of the second inning
the youngsters put the fills on the
board
[Applause]
and a pop-up
buster coming over and he makes the
catch
and did chad fairchild wave that off
you got to give it your biggest and best
sell job if you're a buster
[Applause]
that's a tough call
[Music]
so the giants are going to look at it
because you have to push that screen
away
[Music]
[Applause]
so it didn't hit the screen
and according to fairchild buster
trapped it against the screen
which i don't believe he did doesn't
look like it there
looks like he's plenty in the pocket
call the foul ball
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
they're not booing they're just saying
cabler they're good if you could read
kepler's lips he said can we talk about
what you guys saw i think that's fair
i know you're not supposed to walk out
there but
and by the way major league baseball has
released
their determination on that replay
and it was what we mentioned after
reviewing all relevant angles the replay
official could not definitively
determine that the ball failed to strike
the netting
prior
to the fielder catching the ball
now segora who had a fielder's choice in
his first played appearance
grab all softly off the mound crawford
picks it up and throws in time to get
segora who comes up olympic
segura hit the bad bag awkwardly
paul bukai comes out immediately the
phillies athletic trainer
oh man i'm ruff that's that knee that he
did the other night in new york for a
hammy
well
i don't know if he's going to be back in
joe girardi's got the lineup card out
[Music]
and it puts runners on first and second
with the ostrimski coming up two balls
two strikes wheeler ready to go and the
pitch
swag gonna miss
he got him with a slider three sliders
for strikes against yaski
and zach wheeler picked a fine tie to
pick up his first strikeout have
something to cook it here first and
second with nobody out
and brad miller coming up
and that one's hit to right field going
back on indies ribs back to the
scoreboard it is gone
a three-run home run
first homer of the year for miller
and the phillies leading four-nothing
wheeler will go after buster posey
brandon crawford and austin slater
and buster on the first pitch
high drive
left field out of here
it's the second pitch that posey has
seen
off a wheeler and he hits his third home
run of the year
and so darren ruff draws a walk he's
aboard two out walk will bring up tommy
lestella
the stella hits a high drive to right
it is out of here
so the rough
walk got la stella to the plate and he
hits his first home run of the year and
he picks up his first rbis of the year
and the giants are back in it absolute
no doubter to right field
it's sharply towards short diving stop
may time flips to second in time
excellent play and it certainly helped
zach wheeler in the fills
yeah that'll bring bone to the plate
boom hit sends one of the air to deep
left field it is
gone two-run home run he jumped on it
and the phillies lead it six to three
that's the way to get a comfort back
second home run of the year for balm he
now has 10 runs batted in
what a pretty swing pretty and
strong
here's buster posey
[Applause]
buster hits a high drive to left he's
done it again
out of here
on a high fastball high fastball 3-2 up
and in
you have to be so short and so quick to
the ball at the velocity that this man
throws the ball and he does exactly that
101.5 off the bat
[Music]
joyce slams it to right yastrinsky
slides and makes the catch
and that'll end the inning
so with one outrunners on first and
second dickerson's coming up
high drive
right field
it
is out of here
and the giants take delay
the first runs that connor brockton has
given up in 15 and two-thirds innings
did we mention he had a score on the
street going yes we do
and now flores to bat
here with runners on the corners
flores hits a high drive to left
it is out of here
a three-run home run the second in the
inning
and the giants lead 10 to six
the first runs that connor brockton has
given up
priest thought he had a day off ends up
getting three at bats yeah
and a high fly ball to deep left center
field that's going for a ride it's gone
a solo home run for reese
it's a 10-7 ball game
and that's where he threw it and his
sway ain't going to miss and that's the
ball game